brother for another follows the show
every single day here on nbc sports on
peacock and joining us here uh prior to
that show with his co-host michael holly
is michael smith back here how are you
michael
man i'm great how y'all doing i am doing
well uh all right i'll i'll let you in
on i'm sure what you're gonna be talking
about later on uh if the urban meyer
hiring is a cautionary tale what is it
and for whom michael smith
first of all let me just tell you how
happy i am about this story
[Laughter]
come on michael i'm so happy that urban
meyer has been fired i woke up so happy
this morning until i fired up madden 22
franchise mode just to fire urban meyer
again
wow
just a good measure
okay
just to just because just i'm so happy
that
this has reached this
which should have been an inevitable
conclusion
you asked
if it's a cautionary tale for whom
i think it's a cautionary tale for
for business
um
across the board for
anybody looking for a ceo because what i
don't like is and this happens every
time a college coach fails
as if
nfl coordinators don't fail
as if we haven't seen
some college coaches come into the nfl
and make it a lot of them come from
college maybe they gain some nfl
experience along the way
before becoming a head coach
others failed
at the nfl level for a variety of
reasons
urban meyer failed for
one reason and one reason only and that
was because he lacked character this was
this was not about
coaching acumen this wasn't about x's
and o's or schemes this was about
an arrogant so-and-so
thinking that he could talk down to
people even his assistant coaches
because most people when they think
about college coaches like all these
players you're the grown men so are your
freaking assistants that you hired
so calling them losers or having the
nerve to kick another grown man he lucky
to get his ass kicked by josh rambo
like
to who does that at any level
like this doesn't this shouldn't this
shouldn't fly in college and it goes to
show you that somebody can be successful
and not be a good person
like this is one of the most successful
coaches in college football history and
if he was doing this throughout his
tenure at bowling green or utah or
florida or ohio state if this is how he
conducted himself then those programs
somehow managed to succeed
more in spite of urban meyer than
because of urban meyer that's what i
think shah khan underestimated and
frankly it's what i underestimated i
thought he had enough good sense to
humble himself and do exactly what he
what coaches ask their players to do
which is to adjust
coaching is about adjusting with you
first and foremost
and the fact that he refused
to adjust
his
approach
at the nfl level despite not receiving
the results is it's mind-boggling if you
look at the timeline and a lot of people
have laid it out of all the stories you
cover with covered with urban meyer
most of them have to do with somebody
just being a jerk
or being arrogant
or his ego
not not to mention that the team wasn't
getting any better so i don't know that
it's a general cautionary tale about
staying away from college coaches i
think it's a cautionary tale about
making sure you understand the kind of
person you're putting in charge of your
organization whether that's in the nfl
or anywhere i i i i hear you michael
smith and in terms of you know um i i
i'm shocked by it um because you know
i'll repeat what i said the last hour uh
here again
we at nfl network um you know we've
we've had coaches on with us david shaw
has been our first night uh um main set
mainstay for us from from stanford and
then in the second um night we went
through a period of time where we would
have another coach college coach come on
2016 was urban meyer in chicago
and that guy who showed up on that set
knew everything about every kid that was
on that stage okay and he was able to
uh he was engaged he was locked in he
was knowledgeable about everybody there
i can't believe that guy
didn't know
when he was asked this week about one of
his players and andre cisco him saying i
don't have the numbers in front of me
but he's playing a little bit more and
he had zero defensive snaps right i i
honestly i i can't compute maybe he's
just different he's all you know older
or
the loss is just you know
that that's to to me like you want to
talk about the character issues that's
one thing
there's also incompetence that i saw
that i couldn't
fathom i just couldn't fathom that how
about incompetence coupled with
indifference because maybe it was a
maybe it was a money grab all along
and maybe he's something of a
frontrunner he's won everywhere he's
been
uh and everybody talks about how hard he
takes losses maybe it's one of those
where he just wasn't
in in a mood to really rebuild maybe it
was harder than he thought it was gonna
be
and once he got in and realized wait a
minute this is actually going to take
work maybe he checked out i'm with you
how do you go 187 and 32 with three
national championships and not be good
like i don't even blame shaw khan for
all of the personality flaws which many
people knew and all the missteps that he
that urban meyer had when it came to
issues of character
nonetheless
the dude was one of the most successful
coaches in college football history
that's not a bad gamble to make that he
can't transition into the nfl
sometimes it's not that you read the
person wrong sometimes the person
is just not
who they have been you're absolutely
right maybe he's a different guy
than the one who had been successful at
all those different stops because it
wasn't just that it's
you know it's the james robinson
situation is whether or not trevor
lawrence can execute a quarterback sneak
or not
it's of course staying behind who stays
behind after a loss like
coach
even college coaches don't do that i
don't know maybe maybe he did it where
he was because the bottom line is this
michael smith um
when you look at at an nfl head coaching
jobs okay
to get a five-year contract
okay in a state where there is no state
income tax
and
an owner who is not known
um
as meddlesome by any stretch of the
imagination right who has shown patience
with doug morone and gus bradley before
you okay yeah and you're handed one of
the most generationally talented
quarterbacks
as your as your first selection
with another first round selection to
boot okay that is truly one of the most
plum nfl jobs that i've seen given to
anybody
in my 18 years with nfl network and
covering this day in and day out
and for this job
and for this to be the result is
still
something that it's going to take more
than just this show this day this week
for me to fathom can't believe it can't
believe it intentional
what do you mean by that what do you
mean by that i just mean self-sabotage
like i mean
you you okay
if you do something as egregious as stay
behind
and and hang out and get caught on video
with the woman that's not your wife in
ohio while your team travels home
after a loss winless
on the year still yeah right
and live to tell about it
and the owner says you got to regain our
trust
most committed people
would
go out of their way
to change
to to have some kind of self-awareness
and to say hey you know what i gotta i
gotta straighten up and fly right
because i'm already on probation
instead it's almost as if he tried to
one-up himself
and dig himself a deeper hole
he just didn't want to be he seemed like
he didn't want to be there not only was
he disconnected
he was disinterested in being there
and along the way
just kept doing things i mean
we can't i'm sure we broke down film or
or you know got into some of the
strategic decisions there are missteps
there as well but his high profile
missteps strictly come from a place of
hubris
and and that's why i don't and i'm glad
you mentioned somebody like a david shaw
i just hope that this doesn't become a
conversation about college coaches
because there's a lot of good men
coaching college football
who have the ability to coach at the
next level some of them came from the
nfl to college i just don't want this to
be some kind of black mark on college
football or college football coaches who
are excellent teachers this is strictly
an urban meyer
character issue this is about him
and again whoever he was at ohio state
and in florida if he was doing stuff
like kicking people
or kicking kickers and calling them
names and calling assistant losers and
berating people that way
that's not leadership on any level in
any arena michael smith here on the rich
eyes show by the way i'll talk about
david shaw any time if i'm an owner
that's that's who i call up i call him
and say here's a blank check david you
come i've told you you know what i'm
saying i've told him that i've also told
him that my my sons are are now
currently ages 13 and 10. they might not
play football but can he at least
consider offering them right now you
know
20 in 20 20 32. you know what i mean
like uh honestly i
i i think the world and by the way part
of the reason why david shaw would work
at the next level is he's worked at this
level before and he's been around
winning organizations and he knows what
winners look like and sound like and and
he's got character coming out of every
pore of his body so i always push it but
if you you know rich in it again in any
walk of life
you know he who knows not and knows that
he knows not
there's wisdom there
okay and most coaches most successful
people
most successful leaders
surround themselves with smart people
and let them do their jobs
and if you don't know something you
don't pretend like you're the smartest
person in the room and i just can't
understand for the life of me how his
ego could have been so out of control
that even in the face of diminishing
returns
he wouldn't adjust and adapt and say hey
you know what
my way doesn't work here
if he wanted this thing to work he would
have adjusted but it goes back to what
we've been saying there was something
that just he didn't he didn't want it he
didn't after a while he just didn't want
it because
early he had enough time to get it
together for an owner
who if this story in the tampa times
doesn't come out urban meyer is still a
coach today
maybe so michael smith brother from
another here on the rich eisen show how
about coach prime how about coach prime
how about your boy how about it right
you changed your boy how about that what
are you what's your two cents on that
something are you talking about him when
was when were you talking about him
when he wanted to swag or come out here
oh you know i i talk about him all the
time i love him there was one in
particular i saw uh well it was
yesterday and it was also a few a few
weeks ago too when uh when he was
beginning to start uh
showing some success
at uh jackson state
and telling everybody that florida state
made a mistake you know they made a
mistake and that he is he is the type of
coach that can succeed
in today in today's day and age of of
college football and and yesterday just
proves that he's he's he's he wants to
do it where he is not not like just win
enough games to go somewhere else like
he's
he's for real like that's this is for
real and anybody who doesn't realize it
you're just overlooking him again just
because he's flashy or whatever he's
serious guys should be taken seriously i
hope that's no question i mean i hope i
hope this is for the long haul no reason
i say hope is not that that may not be
his intention but
somebody in his in their right mind in
one of these power five schools
is gonna realize that he's not just the
show that the guy can coach
and he can lead and build a program
somebody will make him an offer and i
hope for the sake of
jackson state i hope for the sake of of
you know this resurgence of hbcus if i
may um
i hope that that this is i hope that he
can be a modern day eddie robinson of
sorts i mean you you know you're you
know you're an nfl historian you know
what that that the national football
league as we know it does not exist
without the contributions of
historically black colleges and
universities
they used to be
pipelines
um
that that were that were feeder schools
for some of the greatest players in nfl
history the pittsburgh steelers dynasty
was built on hbcus jerry rice you know
exactly some of the greatest players to
ever play the game have come from hbcus
we've gotten to a point in the last
couple years where again writing your
wheelhouse the nfl draft
has devalued
you know uh hbcu players despite
people like uh darius lynn for for
instance
um and so
yeah i believe that this is just the
beginning i don't know that necessarily
people are going to flock to hbcus
you know overnight even in this era of
name image and likeness
but i don't think hunter was was was an
isolated incident or an aberration or an
anomaly whatever you want to call it i
think it was the beginning of something
not just at jackson state but beyond i
mean jackson state set fcs fcs
attendance records last year
you know his son won the jerry rice
award as you know
so there's a he's building a power down
in jackson mississippi meanwhile oh by
the way
love seeing hugh jackson re-emerge at
grambling
that was big this is a great time for
hbcus you got eddie george at where
tennessee stays that's right um it's a
great time for hbcus during this uh i
guess this larger zeitgeist that we're
in in american society i just love also
uh dion proven
i just love it but he proving that again
the the general sense and chris and i
and
tj and i were talking about it yesterday
here on the show
that uh the general sense that the nil
and transfer portals were just gonna be
the uh the destruction of college
football in many ways because the rich
were gonna get richer the power five the
blue bloods were going to get bluer
right because of all this green and
here's dion down in jackson mississippi
saying oh okay um we'll just take travis
hunter and not just from anybody but
from the school that didn't hire him
even though he's from that school
it's just a chef's kiss man all around
chef's kiss let me let me add to that i
agree with everything you say but i'll
i'll make a slight tweak to it
please please go for it
just like travis hunter
you know just
had to
choose
jackson state yeah
or for that matter in college basketball
you know uh maker chose howard
university
like for dion sanders now whether who
knows what other options were available
maybe there weren't enough to your point
about people underestimating as a coach
dion sanders
it brought his hall of fame brand
to jackson
state so
the name imagine likeness thing and i
saw dion scoff at the idea of a million
and a half
dollar deal
earlier this morning which i appreciate
it because
and as jimbo fisher said now it's just
out in the open
but let's not kid ourselves the money
has always been there for kids and
that's been part of recruiting whether
people wanted to acknowledge it or not
that's been the underbelly of college
sports now it's just legal as elaine
kiffin mentioned
but dion and i know you're not
suggesting this but i just want to make
this clear deon sanders i don't believe
just got travis hunter because name
image and likeness money was attached
deon sanders
beat them at their own gains oh yes
because that name imagine likeness money
it might not have been as lucrative if
assuming that he's getting some or a
large amount anyway maybe it's more
lucrative or maybe it was a great brand
play for travis hunter to be a pioneer
and to buck the system and to go to an
hbcu and that worked well for him versus
if he goes to florida state he's not a
story for two days on national national
radio and television but nonetheless
dion sanders
was able to bring him there because he's
deion sanders because he's building
something special and that's what scares
the establishment
that's what scares them is that he's
building something sustainable and
something that attracts them because
this young man
for him to go to an fcs and hbcu
is is more is more about
the the nurturing nature and the
coaching available to him there and the
environment there yes and and the
competition there
than it is about
a name image and likeness deal of course
that's the scary part for the rest of uh
rest of college football especially
because you can make nil money there too
you know what i'm saying he because he
can make i mean uh dion's son shadow
just signed a deal with tom brady's uh
i'll deal with tom brady
how about that just today that happened
today and i think his son is one of the
top nil earners uh all year
and and that's important i mean let's be
honest if you're making it if you're
making a choice but you also have to
factor in like i said yesterday and i've
seen this firsthand he when dionne would
be on the field at the combine for
defensive back drills he was a godfather
the people flocked to him and kids kids
who were not born when he played
football people who were not born when
he's so relevant
the other day we were talking about i
don't know if you saw he brought in
jackson state alum brittany renner who's
like famous on social media right yes i
did see because he's got to teach these
guys how you know how to check out for
the sliding dms man or not do it you
know like dude that was awesome though
like look at the way the players
responded to that like even though most
of these players probably aren't old
enough to have seen deion sanders play
he has
a
kind of relevance
you know like most kids nowadays know
who michael jordan is and some of it is
just because of the shoes but they knew
michael jordan and they know what a big
deal he was even though they never saw
him play beyond sanders now he's not
that old but most of he still has the
pulse of the players one of the modern
players he still gets it
you know even though they didn't have
dms back in his day there's there's
nothing new
i'm sure he gets it i'm sure i just
think he's pushed so many buttons
from a a off the field standpoint not to
mention 11-1 on the field this year and
winning the swac
i mean he seems to can do no wrong down
there but you're right the the money
being available for the most part across
the board
levels the playing field more than
people thought but dion sanders still
beat them playing by the same rules i
just don't want i just don't like that
people it seems like there's a lot of
people telling on themselves
you know the last couple of days like oh
he must have done something
to you know
out of bounds or being above and beyond
to get this kid to go to an hbcu maybe
this can't just want to go to hbcu and
play for dion sanders what's so
unbelievable about that uh it shouldn't
be uh honestly i
i'll just tell one last time i can't i
can't wait to tell everybody this story
the thing that i'm most sh i'll tell you
again the thing i'm most shocked about
of dion being a good coach
is when
we would watch games together at nfl
network on a sunday and somebody did a
boneheaded play he would scream at the
screen cut him
and then he would cut him he would cut
the kid he would cut that player before
he got back to the sideline
and nobody i i never thought to myself
well that's coach of the year material
right there
that's coaching your material right
there you know about the rooting for him
to stay and build something short
lasting and special at jackson state
just to bring this full circle a little
bit yeah
hypothetically speaking do you think dr
would be a good nfl coach head coach i
wouldn't put anything past him
absolutely
yeah absolutely of course absolutely you
think he knows how to deal with the
media do you think he knows what the
pitfalls are do you think he knows how
to talk to grown men do you think he
knows what makes them tick yeah do you
think i mean of course and the whole
concept that you got to pay your dues
well he's doing that now
you know i mean not anymore i mean you
could sit there and say that you know
um
what taking the job that he took was a
do paying thing but he's basically
making sure everybody is
you know sowing what he's reaping
and that's uh that that is building but
you know
and that's exactly right like
you know him better than i do reaping
what he's sewing yeah you know you know
better than i do but dude's paying from
the standpoint of like
it just doesn't seem like jackson state
is a stepping stone for him well i don't
know you know i i i can't sit here and
and say what what's in his future or
what's in his mind other than the fact
that he wants but his motivation he
wants to dominate there that i know
that's what he wants to do and show that
he can do it and you know where wherever
he's at and i think you know knowing him
he's truly one of the most loyal guys
i've ever been around and that he takes
that very seriously like if you pay him
the respect and loyalty he will give it
right back to you in kind friendship and
and professional that the the the brass
at jackson state saying come here i
think that means a lot to him
i think it means a ton because i'm
asking you as somebody who knows him
like i i threw out the hypothetical
about him being a pro coach and that
that's you know okay climbs the ladder
you know he maybe maybe a power fire
school makes him an offer he can't
refuse right three to five years or
whatever and then on to the pros and
blah blah that's way down the road but
conversely i'm just talking about his
motivation
he seems like somebody who's perfectly
content
as you mentioned sewing
back into the culture
giving back and and molding young men
uh in an environment that you know he
was one of a couple years ago he was one
or really i think it was last year he
was one of the most outspoken people
saying how we gotten to a point where
the nfl doesn't draft one single player
out of hbcu so it feels like
even though he could be a pro coach it
feels like maybe college is his calling
is that is that going well i think it's
just it's teaching and teaching kids i
think he really digs it i think he
really likes it and a perfect example
again about how seriously he takes it i
feel like you know
maybe members of this listening and
viewing audience are kind of like the
the captive audience here in the studio
with tj and brockman who's kind of like
my wife susie he's heard all my stories
um i'll tell this one to you if you
haven't heard it but the night that dion
got into the hall of fame that's the
clip i saw but tell it again anyway it's
a great story yeah the night that dion
got in the hall of fame
he was you know we were holding the
ceremony live on nfl network the
announcement ceremony i was hosting it
and uh he was he brought his youth
football team to the super bowl that
year
and
uh the time in which the announcement
took place was during practice
and he said to the nfl network i'm not
coming and we're like
dion like this is the hall of fame this
is the super bowl this is on nfl network
you're a colleague you're you you work
for nfl now what do you mean you're not
coming he's like i'm not gonna do it
because i can't
you know i can't leave practice and um
and uh and tell these kids
that
my individual achievement is more
important than their uh practice
and so i think the the
um the compromise was nfl network sent a
car there and he left it waiting until
practice was over and he showed up uh to
the ceremony in uh with his whistle
around his neck
and
pissed too by the way he was not he's
not happy he was you were there he was
not happy and it's like normally the
most exciting moment in somebody's life
not happy about it
that's fact that happened so that should
give you a window into what what he's
what texts meanwhile he's doing aflac
commercials yeah nick saban hey man
that's great he has not taken a back
seat to anybody that's dionne he's high
stepping thanks for the call love our
chats always michael smith have a great
show with michael holly later on take
care appreciate joe hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here